was hoping to become a lawyer but after
completing his studies he decided to
become a farmer instead
in 2016 he launched his company champion
against the advice of his parents and
devoted his time to growing food
digital technology has always been at
the forefront of his work
he uses apps to get advice on optimal
farming methods
right now he's getting some tips for his
rice field
these tools have played a key role in
his career choice
he sees himself as more of an
agricultural entrepreneur or agripreneur
than a farmer
avex's
with these apps and with the internet
we're able to find solutions to the
problems we encounter and that has been
a huge plus for us
the new generation of agripreneurs
agriculture is a leading sector in ivory
coast representing nearly a third of gdp
but global warming and deforestation are
weighing on the environment
could digital technology revolutionize
the sector
the company investive is convinced it
can and is trying to preserve the
country's remaining forests with
precision agriculture
they want to make a clear distinction
between protected forest and farmland
with the help of drones
could it fall on our heads by accident
the photos taken by the drone show the
farmers exactly what belongs to them and
what belongs to the forest where they're
not allowed to fell trees
he has his map and knows he owns one
hectare he won't go beyond that and
encroach on the forest
back in the village the footage is
analyzed and clearly shows the
boundaries between the forest and the
fields
you can work anywhere in this area but
you can't enter here
this is a small revolution previously he
would have had to walk around his field
with gps to obtain this data
work that would normally take us two or
three hours now only takes us one hour
so that's really good
so far few people in ivory coast have
access to such data
while almost everyone has a cell phone
today less than half the population has
internet access
it's often too expensive especially for
farmers
is trying to popularize the use of apps
among farmers
he explains the wide scope of
opportunities that the internet presents
but he knows a lot has to change to
achieve real success
it would be good if we could have free
internet zones in the villages where
people could get wireless access and get
online that would be really good
and time is of the essence
in the heart of the country
rain is scarce and the land is dry
researchers at the agricultural college
in yamasucro are developing an app that
will help people to adjust to climate
change
farmers can access this information and
apply it accordingly depending on the
condition of their fields
the scientists use meteorological data
from the nasa website
our goal isn't to accurately predict the
weather it's to determine the right time
during the plant's growth cycle to carry
out certain agricultural activities
agriculture
researchers also want the app to be able
to respond precisely to the needs of the
farmers
given the drought and the need to
irrigate
rain is a major concern
okay but does the app take rainfall into
account because there might not be
enough
eventually the app should calculate the
amount of water the farmers should use
depending on the rainfall
it allows us to anticipate problems that
would normally take us by surprise
digitalization is hoped to solve another
big problem for farmers
access to new markets in the cities
marie luoquindo runs a juice bar in
abidjan
she buys her fruit at the market but
there are always problems with
deliveries
the new online platform that brings
producers and buyers together could save
her from these constant disruptions
the suppliers give us dates when the
items will be available and then due to
logistics problems they're not available
in abidjan
the app could also help farmers to sell
their produce more effectively
by consolidating information about crop
yields from across the country
there could be a shortage of bananas in
the north of ivory coast for example and
over production in the south so our idea
is to allow farmers in the south where
there's an over production to be able to
sell their products in the north
it will take time for the virtual market
to function well nationwide
agricultural entrepreneur valtter
yaokovi doesn't want to wait that long
he organises training for young people
who want to help the country move
forward with digital agriculture
when young people on social media see
others like them who went to school and
got diplomas but then returned to the
countryside to this land that feeds
people i think that will create jobs
he hopes to create a real community of
networked organic farmers across the
country
you